[Musique]
face au défi du changement climatique
réinventer la ville est devenue une
apparieuse nécessité c'est vrai que les
transports la construction l'aménagement
même la consommation sont en pleine
mutation alors comment Saint-Quentin se
prépare justement à cette révolution
bien c'est le thème de ce nouveau numéro
de ski Mag et je suis avec Laurent
Mercer bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
maire de montillons on est chez vous là
dans l'hyperso entre on va en parler et
vous êtes aussi premier vice-président
de de l'agglomération chargée du
l'urbanisme et de l'aménagement du
territoire alors c'est très intéressant
je disais on est chez vous on est dans
ce qu'on appelle l'hypercentre zone
typiquement urbaine il y avait des
parkings un centre commercial il y a des
dalles et c'est aussi intéressant parce
que on est dans une partie qui commence
à être changé puis derrière nous il y a
le quartier de la gare qui va être en
pleine rénovation c'est ça oui on va
avoir une transformation totale du
quartier Patrice effectivement avec ce
bâtiment rouge qui est situé derrière
nous et qui va bientôt disparaître pour
laisser place à un programme de le
bureau de 25 mm carré on appelle
l'anneau rouge ce bâtiment que nous
appelons l'anneau rouge effectivement
qui aujourd'hui nous masque la gare donc
demain et bien la gare sera à nouveau
visible on la verra de la ville et puis
depuis la gare on verra ce que nous
avons en face de nous c'est à dire un
condensé de ce qui est
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de ce qu'est
le territoire c'est-à-dire à la fois du
logement à la fois de l'activité mais
aussi de la nature nous avons le parc
des sources qui démarque ici et donc
nous avons dans cette zone absolument un
condensé de ce qu'est
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et c'est un
aménagement qui a 40 ans aujourd'hui
donc qui présentait déjà à l'époque de
grands avantages puisque il y avait la
mixité des fonctions logements commerce
enseignement
culture et activités économique donc ça
c'est une c'est vertueux mais par contre
comme vous le disiez c'est un
aménagement extrêmement minéral parce
qu'à l'époque on donnait de la noblesse
et il y avait des enjeux
autour du réchauffement climatique vous
voyez cette place il y a encore quelques
des années c'était un parking voilà une
illustration d'un des premiers
aménagements des premiers changements de
ce quartier qui s'est opéré ici
aujourd'hui nous avons des espaces verts
nous avons des armes et c'est ce que
nous souhaitons faire dans la continuité
des travaux qui vont se dérouler
dorénavant sur le quartier il y a
d'ailleurs un début de
alors c'est une c'est une preuve de
l'agilité de Saint-Quentin nous
accueillons les épreuves des jop en 2024
et dans ce cadre là évidemment il était
un peu tôt pour faire pousser les arbres
suffisamment grand pour créer de Londres
pour l'année prochaine donc en attendant
nous avons cet aménagement qui une fois
que les épreuves seront passées pour
être installés ailleurs ou c'est
nécessaire sur le territoire
l'aménagement du territoire il s'est
fait
aussi en concertation avec la population
alors ça aussi ça a été une des grandes
démarches effectivement aujourd'hui qui
devient un incontournable c'est que on
doit travailler avec les habitants et
c'est ce qui s'est passé ici puisque
nous avons organisé un grand nombre
d'ateliers des malades urbaines nous
avons consulté à la fois les habitants
du quartier mais aussi les salariés des
entreprises qui sont sur le territoire
les étudiants les gens qui fréquentent
les commerces les commerçants de façon à
pouvoir avoir un projet qui soit partagé
par tous et donc le projet qui se met en
oeuvre aujourd'hui et qui va se dérouler
dans les prochains mois de
réhabilitation de tous ces espaces que
nous allons dans lesquels nous allons
circuler et bien c'est le projet tel
qu'il a été voulu par une grande
majorité d'avisions de la population
voilà il y a de la concertation donc on
va vers la végétalisation on va aussi
vers des modes de transport plus doux
comme on dit alors vous voyez derrière
nous nous avons la gare et on l'aperçoit
d'ici nous avons une agence de la
mobilité c'est ça et nous avons aussi
notre dispositif de de location de vélo
en lien avec la région et donc tout ça
va ensemble en fait tout ça va ensemble
mais jusqu'ici tout ce quartier était
l'un des seuls du territoire à être mal
irrigué au niveau des pistes cyclables
donc l'un des grands enjeux de
céréaménagement au-delà des espaces
verts que nous souhaitons créer
précisément de pouvoir mettre de la
mobilité douce au cœur du quartier pour
permettre à la fois aux gens du
territoire qui vont travailler de venir
à vélo jusqu'à la gare et à l'inverse
pour les salariés qui viennent
travailler de pouvoir depuis la gare
et qui donc va permettre effectivement
aux gens d'utiliser ces moyens là plutôt
que la voiture alors j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle pour vous c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de Montigny dans la vie
il y a aussi d'autres quartiers d'autres
villes qui procèdent des rénovations et
il y a notamment la ville de La Verrière
avec le quartier des bécanes et je vous
propose de rejoindre votre collègue
Nicolas Dainville qui nous explique en
quoi consiste cette rénovation
Laza qui garde bécane la zone
d'aménagement concerté-garbécane c'est
le projet du siècle pour la verrière
avec une première étape décisive qui
consiste à aménager les terrains Denis
forestiers qui appartient à la MGEN et
qui va voir la création d'un coeur de
ville qui respecte l'esprit village avec
une place avec un marché qui à
l'ambition d'attirer davantage de
services une crèche notamment de
commerce la restauration et qui
ambitionne d'être extrêmement innovant
en matière d'écologie
[Musique]
on vise le label EcoQuartier on
utilisera les matériaux les plus
respectueux les plus innovants on aura
tout un système de récupération des eaux
et on réfléchit d'ores et déjà un réseau
de chaleur qui conciliera la facture
énergétique la moins élevée possible
mais également la performance
énergétique la plus respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]
ce projet d'aménagement est directement
lié à la gare on a la chance à La
Verrière d'avoir une gare qui rayonne la
gare est en pleine métamorphose on a un
nouveau parking relais qui vient
d'ouvrir on aura à terme à parvis piéton
pour avoir un vrai quartier de la gare
avec prochainement on l'espère une
brasserie ou de nouveaux services
[Musique]
on est dans cette perspective du château
on a une histoire du château à
s'extraordinaire liée au trésor de
Napoléon et donc on va essayer d'avoir
un nouveau quart de ville qui met en
avant cette histoire de la verrière qui
soit respectueux de l'esprit village et
ça c'est notre ambition et notre
exigence avec des toits pentus avec des
volets en tertiène avec également une
petite fontaine comme on peut en trouver
dans les villages provençaux provinciaux
qui en général rassurent qui font appel
à un imaginaire du village d'antan qu'on
aimerait bien recréer en termes
d'ambiance pour la verrière
on vient de voir le quartier des bécanes
à la verrière et évidemment il y a
d'autres communes de l'agglomération qui
sont en pleine rénovation oui en fait
tout le territoire de Saint-Quentin est
concerné par l'aménagement durable on
pourrait citer le quartier des savoirs à
Guyancourt nous avons aussi ce qui est
en train de se passer avec la réflexion
sur le centre-ville de plaisir il y a
tout le travail qui est fait également
sur le plateau urbain de trappes et je
pourrais citer comme ça toutes les
communes du territoire donc c'est vrai
que c'est un enjeu qui est très fort que
la communauté d'agglomération a vraiment
saisi à bras le corps et nous avons une
évolution nous avons un territoire
plutôt réussi mais qui aujourd'hui doit
franchir un cap en matière d'aménagement
et c'est le pas que nous sommes en train
de faire alors on parle de réchauffement
climatique et c'est pas hasard il fait
une température moi je commence à des
petites taches sur ma chemise c'est le
réchauffement climatique ça existe oui
alors on est on est toujours dans les
personnes dans un autre périmètre qui
celui de du théâtre qui est là de
l'avenue du centre qui est là et qu'il
alors lui aussi est un quartier qui va
être en pleine
ah oui qui va être complètement
transformé puisque ce théâtre que vous
venez de citer va connaître enfin il y a
30 ans qu'il aurait dû avoir dès le
départ et donc il va connaître demain
avec à l'intérieur non seulement un lieu
d'accueil pour le théâtre mais une
brasserie également un café restaurant
donc il y a je voudrais de la
convivialité également et l'aménagement
de la place donc il va être complètement
transformé on a une place de coeur de
ville qui a été aménagé en entrée de
ville et qui était aménagé
demain on rend la place aux piéton on
rend la place à l'humain on redonne de
la mobilité pour les personnes on va
replanter des arbres pour que cette
lieux devienne une véritable place de
centre-ville même chose sur l'avenue du
centre même chose sur l'avenue du centre
puisque les voitures ne pourront plus
utiliser que les deux voies de droite
dans un sens et dans l'autre et que tout
le reste demain sera dédié là aussi à la
fois aux espaces piétonniers aux
plantations de végétation d'arbres et de
pistes cyclables qui permettront de
relier à parfois le reste de la ville la
zone d'activité la zone économique mais
aussi le Vélodrome et l'île de loisirs
qui sont situés par là à quelques
centaines de mètres d'ailleurs on
aperçoit derrière nous des images
virtuelles mais enfin de ce que sera le
quartier donc combien de temps justement
et bien écoutez les travaux ont déjà
démarré puisque nous parlions de la
neuroche tout à l'heure et les travaux
sur l'avenue du centre et sur la place
Pompidou vont démarrer dans les
prochains mois
de à peu près
le théâtre et ce qui concerne l'avenue
du centre et la place Pompidou la grosso
modo deux années de travaux et puis
ensuite nous poursuivrons sur le bassin
et sur le canal alors on est dans un
paysage urbain on l'a vu il est vraiment
vraiment urbain l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin il y a aussi de
l'agriculture je crois que c'est 20% à
peu près des des terrains sont dédiés à
l'agriculture et justement je parlais de
la manière de consommer qui est en train
de changer et je vous propose de
découvrir une ferme qui est un menu des
hameau c'est la ferme de la la Closeraie
qui est sur des terrains qui
appartiennent à 50 ans en Yvelines et je
vous propose de rencontrer Robert Pirès
qui ne dure que par le BIOS et par les
circuits courts ça veut dire les AMAP
mon installation en agriculture c'est
une conversion une reconversion à la
fois professionnelle mais aussi de
reconversion de vie en fait tout
simplement moi je venais d'une toute
autre activité plutôt administrative
donc j'ai essayé sans avoir la certitude
que je resterai dans ce métier
[Musique]
ça peut être un parcours du combattant
ça n'a pas été pour moi parce que je
suis tombé assez vite au moment de ma
recherche de terre je suis tombé assez
vite sur sur le opportunité qui
s'offrait ici cette volonté à la fois de
l'Agglo de Saint-Quentin et de la
commune de Magny-les-Hameaux d'installer
d'installer des paysans sur ce terrain
ce qui m'a permis déjà d'appréhender ce
terrain qui à l'époque était une friche
et de me rendre compte peut-être il
pouvait se passer quelque chose là j'ai
répondu à l'appel à candidature et
j'étais retenu alors on était fin 2000
fin 2013 donc rien été fait à l'époque
[Musique]
la possibilité de s'installer pour pour
l'agriculteur en étant en étant aidé
soutenu voire même lancer en fait par
une collectivité territoriale donc ce
qui a été ce qui a été une chance pour
moi peut certainement l'être pour
d'autres aussi et c'est quelque chose
qui en fait montre aussi l'implication
en fait d'acteurs locaux dans un
changement et en fait qui mieux qu'une
commune qu'une collectivité territoriale
qui mieux que peut insuffler ce
changement certainement aussi avec des
avec des citoyens mais cette chose là en
fait elle est pour moi elle est même
bénéfique en fait quand c'est quand
c'est possible quand ça devient je
trouve ça super
[Musique]
le projet c'était évidemment de
développer
l'agriculture respectueuse de la terre
mais qui soit localement à destination
des populations
de l'agglo en tout cas moi c'est comme
ça que j'ai été formé ma volonté et ça
ça a été annoncé dès le départ c'était
livré des légumes dans le cadre de
paniers hebdomadaire en AMAP et mes
collègues de même travaillent en circuit
court et aussi ils ont des AMAPs à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc dans
notre sur d'autres communes de l'agglo
Laurent Merker vous êtes maire de beauté
dit vous êtes le premier vice-président
de l'agglomération cherchent du
l'urbanisme et de l'aménagement du
territoire et on est justement ici dans
le quartier des canaux du canal
qui lui aussi
va beaucoup changer oui il va être
complètement transformé puisqu'on va
retirer une partie de ce qui aujourd'hui
et d'évoluer au bassin pour planter des
arbres puisque là nous sommes en pleine
terre il y a pas de dalle il y a pas de
parking donc c'est un lieu où on peut
mettre de la nature et à profusion et de
la même façon on va complètement revoir
aussi l'aménagement de ce canal qui
aujourd'hui est essentiellement il est
bâtonné et bas et donc demain on veut
faire remonter l'eau pour qu'elle soit
vraiment au niveau de la voirie et on va
remettre de la nature de part et d'autre
du canal de façon à un canal qui aura
l'air beaucoup plus naturel qui sera
aussi
un canal qu'on pourra approcher
puisqu'il y aura des espaces où nous
pourrons nous poser tout au long de ce
canal donc une présence de l'eau une
présence de l'eau vertueuse puisque nous
récupérons les eaux pluviales du
quartier Saint-Quentin et nous aurons un
fond beaucoup moins profond donc nous
utiliserons beaucoup moins d'eau donc à
la fois garder la présence de l'eau en
ville plus présente et en même temps que
l'économies exactement alors voilà on
est ici à Montigny mais
dans le périmètre de la ville nouvelle
de Saint-Quentin c'est à dire
des années 80-90 ou des enjeux n'étaient
pas les mêmes
bâtiments des logements des bureaux
évidemment il va falloir les rénover
extrêmement fort et la crise énergétique
que nous traversons depuis l'année
dernière nous le rappelle davantage
encore il faut impérativement faire
évoluer les bâtiments les bâtiments
publics bien sûr mais aussi les
bâtiments privés et les bâtiments
sociaux ça pour les bâtiments sociaux
c'est ce que nous avons fait a commencé
à faire avec depuis plusieurs années
déjà il y a d'ailleurs un exemple très
très fort ici avec les bâtiments du
bailleur toi et joie qui ont été
complètement revu et transformés avec
dès aujourd'hui à une isolation
extrêmement importante et nous allons
poursuivre ça et puis évidemment il y a
tout le travail de sensibilisation et
d'accompagnement des particuliers des
privés des copropriétés pour leur
permettre elles aussi de pouvoir évoluer
dans ce domaine là juste bon il y a pour
eux une agence qui est l'agence locale
de l'énergie du climat avec
on peut voilà si on veut faire rénover
sa maison ou son appartement on peut
aller voir il y a des conseillers il y a
aussi des aides qui sont qui sont
possibles et bien je vous propose de de
savoir comment bénéficier des conseils
et peut-être des aides de la MEC et on
retrouve pour ça encore un de vos
collègues Jean-Baptiste amonique qui est
le maire de Villepreux qui explique
comment présidente absolument
vice-président de synchronise
et qui va nous expliquer comment pouvoir
bénéficier des conseils et peut-être des
aides de la dette
aujourd'hui quand vous voulez faire
quelques travaux sur votre logement vous
ne savez peut-être pas comment vous y
prendre vous ne savez pas par où
commencer et donc avec les équipes de la
lettre il y a des conseils qui sont
proposés sur les matériaux sur le type
d'isolation qu'il faudrait faire en
priorité sur les différents appareils
qu'il faut changer
[Musique]
on a besoin d'accompagner sur le terrain
je prends l'exemple des balades
thermiques les balades thermiques
permettent de se rendre compte que on a
parfois des logements qui ont besoin
d'être habilités qui ont besoin de
bénéficier de certains travaux
il y a aussi le conseil sur les aides
financières et c'est souvent là où les
particuliers ne s'y retrouvent pas
puisque il y en a une multitude je pense
à ma prime rénove je pense au certificat
d'économie d'énergie sur l'année 2022 la
lettre a pu apporter plus de 3000
conseils
[Musique]
création de cette association s'est
faite sur le territoire de Saint-Quentin
mais aujourd'hui le périmètre est
beaucoup plus large beaucoup plus étendu
on travaille avec la communauté de la
Haute Vallée de Chevreuse on travaille
avec Versailles Grand Parc on travaille
avec un certain nombre de collectivités
d'interconnalités le parc national aussi
régional le PNR ce qui permet d'avoir un
rayonnement auprès des particuliers sur
l'ensemble de ces territoires mais aussi
d'accompagner les collectivités si on
prend l'exemple de Saint-Quentin l'ALEC
a participé à l'élaboration et à la
construction du Plan climat énergie donc
elle l'a co-construit avec
l'agglomération ce qui montre aussi que
c'est un acteur qui est en
accompagnement des politiques publiques
locales portées par les élus
[Musique]
voilà le nouveau
pour les autres et puis celui-ci qui
préfigure nous l'espérons le
réaménagement de l'habitat sur cette
partie de la ville oui bâtiment du futur
mais qui est déjà en place ça veut dire
que ben voilà quand on parle de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique de
transition écologique demain c'est
aujourd'hui quoi oui c'est ça absolument
les toutes ces préoccupations que nous
portons il faut que les choses se
mettent en oeuvre et c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer actuellement merci
beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]